(static crackles)
[Announcer] Hey kids,
do you want a friend
who will never leave your side?
(child chuckles)
Introducing...
Chauncey The Bear!
He'll never leave you.
Never ever.
(woman screams)
(static crackles)
[Dr. Bloom] It's nice
to see you again, Alice.
Jessica told me you've been
spending time with a new friend?
[Alice] He doesn't want me
to talk to you.
(static crackles)
Chauncey?
My favorite thing is his eyes.
I can see anything I can
imagine in them.
(ominous music)
- He asked you to do something
that hurt you.
(ominous music continues)
(Alice cries)
[Gloria] Every culture has
a name for it.
We call them imaginary friends.
(ominous music continues)
Just because you stop
believing in them
doesn't mean they're gone.
And they're angry that you left.
(Alice screams)
- Go!
(creepy music)
(child giggles)
(Taylor inhales)
(Taylor exhales)
(dramatic music)
(plug clicks)
(Chauncey growls)
(Taylor pants)
(light rattles)
(demon growls)
♪ It was just my imagination ♪
♪ Ooh ooh ooh ♪
♪ Running away with me ♪